[Musique]
la remise de prix de la huitième édition
du concours d'embellissement des
collèges s'est déroulée ce mardi 12
septembre domaine des tours elle à la
Plaine des Palmistes
un concours remporté cette année par le
collège Joseph Bédier de Saint-André qui
a reçu un chèque de 4500 € pour
poursuivre l'amélioration du cadre de
vie des élèves
on a fait beaucoup de choses on a
terminé 3e 2e premier on a laissé passer
et aujourd'hui notre vengeance donc
aujourd'hui on est premier on s'est
battu avec nos armes et puis on a gagné
voilà on a plutôt essayé de embellir et
mettre plus de valeur à notre collège
pour avoir plus de pêcheurs
etc
initier en 2012 par le Conseil
départemental le concours
d'embellissement des collèges est une
opération qui associe les élèves et le
personnel des collèges pour
l'aménagement et le fleurissement des
espaces
embellir c'est aussi
pouvoir aller sur la connaissance de
notre biodiversité
portez un projet
créer et créer ensemble
et donc toute cette conscience que cette
conscientisation a été vraiment pris à
coeur par chacun des acteurs qui étaient
présents sur ce projet porté par le
département et ça a été une belle
réussite un bel argument c'est préparer
l'avenir de demain avec notre jeunesse
il y a aussi 20 collèges en participait
à l'édition 2023 qui se décline en
quatre catégories cours jardin hall et
façade la jury composé des luttes
professionnelle et de membres
d'associations à désigner les lauréats
[Musique]